we often hear these days that the
immigration system is broken I want to
make the case today that our immigration
conversation is broken and to suggest
some ways that together we might build a
better one in order to do that I'm going
to propose some new questions about
immigration the United States and the
world questions that might move the
borders of the immigration debate I'm
not going to begin with the feverish
argument that we're currently having
even as the lives and well-being of
immigrants are being put at risk at the
u.s. border and far beyond it instead
I'm going to begin with me in graduate
school in New Jersey in the mid-1990s
earnestly studying US history which is
what I currently teach as a professor at
Vanderbilt University in Nashville
Tennessee and when I wasn't studying
sometimes to avoid writing my
dissertation my friends and I would go
into town to hand out neon colored
fliers protesting legislation that was
threatening to take away immigrants
rights our fliers were sincere they were
well-meaning they were factually
accurate but I realized now they were
also kind of a problem here's what they
said
don't take away immigrant rights to
public education to medical services to
the social safety net they work hard
they pay taxes they're law-abiding they
use social services less than Americans
do they're eager to learn English and
their children serve in the US military
all over the world
now these are of course arguments that
we hear every day immigrants and their
advocates use them as they confront
those who would deny immigrants their
rights or even exclude them from society
and up to a certain point it makes
perfect sense that these would be the
kinds of claims that immigrants
defenders
turn to but in the long-term and maybe
even in the short-term
I think these arguments can be
counterproductive why because it's
always an uphill battle to defend
yourself on your opponent's terrain and
unwittingly the handouts that my friends
and I were handing out and the versions
of these arguments that we hear today
we're actually playing the anti
immigrants game we were playing that
game in part by envisioning that
immigrants were Outsiders rather than as
I'm hoping to suggest in a few minutes
people that are already in important
ways on the inside it's those who are
hostile to immigrants the nativists who
have succeeded in framing the
immigration debate around three main
questions first there's the question of
whether immigrants can be useful tools
how can we use immigrants will they make
us richer and stronger the nativist
answer to this question is no immigrants
have little or nothing to offer the
second question is whether immigrants
are others can immigrants become more
like us are they capable of becoming
more like us of capable of assimilating
are they willing to assimilate here
again the nativist answer is no
immigrants are permanently different
from us and inferior to us and the third
question is whether immigrants are
parasites are they dangerous to us and
will they drain our resources here the
nativist answer is yes and yes
immigrants pose a threat and they SAP
our wealth I would suggest that these
three questions and the nativist animus
behind them have succeeded in framing
the larger contours of the immigration
debate these questions are anti
immigrant and nativist at their core
built around a kind of hierarchical
division of insiders and outsiders
us and them in which only we matter and
they don't and what gives these
questions traction and power beyond the
circle of committed nativists is the way
that they tap into an everyday seemingly
harmless sense of national belonging and
activate it heighten it and inflame it
nativists commit themselves to making
stark distinctions between insiders and
outsiders but the distinction itself is
at the heart of the way nations define
themselves the fissures between inside
and outside which often run deepest
along lines of race and religion are
always there to be deepened and
Exploited and that potentially gives
natives approaches resonance far beyond
those who consider themselves
anti-immigrant and remarkably even among
some who consider themselves
pro-immigrant so for example when
immigrants act allies answer these
questions the native is supposing they
take them seriously they legitimate
those questions and to some extent the
anti-immigrant assumptions that are
behind them when we take these questions
seriously without even knowing it or
reinforcing the closed exclusionary
borders of the immigration conversation
so how did we get here how did these
become the leading ways that we talked
about immigration here we need some
backstory which is where my history
training comes in during the first
century of the us's status as an
independent nation it did very little to
restrict immigration at the national
level in fact many policymakers and
employers worked hard to recruit
immigrants to build up industry and to
serve as settlers to seize the continent
but after the civil war nativist voices
rose in volume and in power the Asian
Latin American Caribbean and European
immigrants who
Doug Americans canals cook their dinners
fought their Wars and put their children
to bed at night were met with a new and
intense xenophobia which cast immigrants
as permanent Outsiders who should never
be allowed to become insiders by the mid
1920s the nativists had one erecting
racist laws that closed out untold
numbers of vulnerable immigrants and
refugees immigrants and their allies did
their best to fight back but they found
himself on the defensive caught in some
ways in the nativists frames when
nativist said that immigrants weren't
useful their allies said yes they are
when nativists accused immigrants of
being others their allies promised that
they would assimilate when nativist
charged that immigrants were dangerous
parasites their allies emphasized their
loyalty their obedience their hard work
and their thrift even as advocates
welcomed immigrants many still regarded
immigrants as outsiders to be pitied to
be rescued to be uplifted and to be
tolerated but never fully brought inside
as equals in rights and respect after
World War Two and especially from the
mid 1960s until really recently
immigrants and their allies turned the
tide overthrowing mid 20th century
restriction and winning instead a new
system that prioritized family
reunification the admission of refugees
and the admission of those with special
skills but even then they didn't succeed
in fundamentally changing the terms of
the debate and so that framework endured
ready to be taken up again in our own
convulsive moment that conversation is
broken the old questions
are harmful and divisive so how do we
get from that conversation to one that's
more likely to get us closer to a world
that is fairer that is more just that's
more secure I want to suggest that what
we have to do is one of the hardest
things that any society can do to redraw
the boundaries of who counts of whose
life whose rights and who's thriving
matters we need to redraw the boundaries
we need to redraw the borders of us in
order to do that we need to first take
on a worldview that's widely held but
also seriously flawed according to that
worldview there's the inside of the
national boundaries inside the nation
which is where we live work and mind our
own business and then there's the
outside there's everywhere else
according to this worldview when
immigrants cross into the nation they're
moving from the outside to the inside
but they remain Outsiders any power or
resources they receive our gifts from us
rather than rights now it's not hard to
see why this is such a commonly held
worldview it's reinforced in everyday
ways that we talk and act and behave
down to the bordered maps that we hang
up in our school rooms the problem with
this worldview is that it just doesn't
correspond to the way the world actually
works and the way it has worked in the
past
of course American workers have built up
wealth in society but so have immigrants
particularly in parts of the American
economy that are indispensable and where
few Americans work like agriculture
since the nation's founding Americans
have been inside the American workforce
of course Americans have built up
institutions in society that guarantee
rights but so with immigrants
they've been there during every major
social movement
like civil rights and organized labor
that have fought to expand rights in
society for everyone so immigrants are
already inside the struggle for rights
democracy and freedom and finally
Americans and other citizens of the
global north haven't minded their own
business and they haven't stayed within
their own borders they haven't respected
other nation's borders they've gone out
into the world with their armies they've
taken over territories and resources and
they've extracted enormous profits from
many of the countries that immigrants
are from in this sense many immigrants
are actually already inside American
power with this different map of inside
and outside in mind the question isn't
whether receiving countries are going to
let Democrats in they're already in the
question is whether the United States
and other countries are going to give
immigrants access to the rights and
resources that their work their activism
and their home countries have already
played a fundamental role in creating
with this new map in mind we can turn to
a set of tough new urgently needed
questions radically different from the
ones we've asked before questions that
might change the borders of the
immigration debate are our three
questions are about workers rights about
responsibility and about equality first
we need to be asking about workers
rights
how do existing policies make it harder
for immigrants to defend themselves and
easier for them to be exploited driving
down wages rights and protections for
everyone when immigrants are threatened
with roundups detention and deportations
their employers know that they can be
abused that they can be told that if
they fight back they'll be turned over
to ice when employers know that they can
terrorize an immigrant with his lack of
papers it makes that worker hyper
exploitable and that has
impacts not only for immigrant workers
but for all workers second we need to
ask questions about responsibility
what role have rich powerful countries
like the United States played in making
it hard or impossible for immigrants to
stay in their home countries picking up
and moving from your country is
difficult and dangerous but many
immigrants simply do not have the option
of staying home if they want to survive
Wars trade agreements and consumer
habits rooted in the global north play a
major and devastating role here what
responsibilities do the United States
European Union and China the world's
leading carbon emitters have to the
millions of people already uprooted by
global warming in the third we need to
ask questions about equality global
inequality is a wrenching intensifying
problem income and wealth gaps are
widening around the world increasingly
what determines whether you're rich or
poor more than anything else is what
country you're born in which might seem
great if you're from a prosperous
country but it actually means a
profoundly unjust distribution of the
chances for a long healthy fulfilling
life when immigrants sent money or goods
home to their family it plays a
significant role in narrowing these gaps
if a very incomplete one it does more
than all the foreign aid programs in the
world combined
we began with the nativist questions
about immigrants as tools as others and
as parasites where might these and new
questions about worker rights about
responsibilities and about equality take
us these questions reject pity and they
embrace justice these questions reject a
nativist
and nationalist division of us versus
them they're going to help prepare us
for problems that are coming and
problems like global warming
that are already upon us it's not going
to be easy to turn away from the
questions that we've been asking towards
this new set of questions it's no small
challenge to take on and broaden the
borders of us it will take wit
inventiveness and courage the old
questions have been with us for a long
time and they're not going to give way
on their own and they're not going to
give way overnight and even if we manage
to change the questions the answers are
going to be complicated and they're
going to require sacrifices and
trade-offs and in an unequal world we're
always going to have to pay attention to
the question of who has the power to
join the conversation and who doesn't
but the borders of the immigration
debate can be moved it's up to all of us
to move them thank you
[Applause]